china you know has embraced capitalism
but it done it in a very authoritarian
way where the government is very much
still in control of the system and that
has made it I think quite hard for
philanthropy to get started because
people are making a lot of money but
they don't want to be too visible about
the fact they've got money because it
seems to call into question the whole
system and but what's happened recently
is that they are looking some of the
wealthy Chinese are looking at their
society and they're seeing there are
huge social problems terrible
environmental problems terrible problems
of poverty of water shortage and so
forth and the government is clearly
struggling to solve those problems on
its own they are looking at people like
Bill Gates and say well that's a good
role model for us you know we think
that's what it means to be a successful
wealthy person now we want to be like
the best American business people but
also we see our own society and we see
there's a need to solve a lot of
problems and I think the government is
now open to encouraging that because it
sees that as a good role model they want
a harmonious society so when they're
seeing the rich give back and that's a
good thing and they're also aware that
they can't solve these problems on their
own and they need to engage the business
community in that and so when there was
an earthquake a huge earthquake that
killed a lot of people last year that
was the first moment where you saw a lot
of the new rich in China actually come
out and start giving substantial amounts
of money and that I think was when the
government for the first time gave its
official nod of approval towards that
phenomena and then you are seeing people
like jet Li the movie star create a
popular culture of giving so with a
million Chinese now giving you know he
has the slogan a 114 a month as the
ideal and they're going by the internet
and the mobile phones and then you also
have this culture of Western companies
that want to do business in China being
expected to give back in the communities
that they are working in particularly
there's a lot of work been going on with
hiv/aids very international community
companies have come in and done work in
that field interestingly talking to Jet
Li one of the issues he's hoping to
solve through his foundation is that
when you're a Western company and you're
asked to do something
but socially good in China you have to
partner with a local organization a
nonprofit or something and they're quite
often you have no idea whether you're
actually working with a good
organization or with a crook who just
wants to take your money and do whatever
with it and he's hoping that he's going
to create a real marketplace with
genuine feedback so that you know as a
Western company for you're doing
business with a bona fide a non-profit
that's actually serious about solving
problems and so you know I think we're
going to see in China over the next five
years this extraordinary take off of
philanthropy appetizing as you get
business philanthropy and nonprofits and
the government or working together to
solve these huge problems of China faces
china i think has been doing a lot of
catching up so far that you had all
these years where it was state dominated
communistic and after Tiananmen Square
the government said we have to embrace
economic growth which means we have to
embrace capitalism otherwise the whole
system is going to crumble and so they
were catching out by copying by doing
copying the successful practices of the
west and basically doing it much cheaper
so they were undercutting us by using a
very cheap labor now there's a real
question about how do they go beyond
that because they've actually you know
probably achieved much of what they can
do by simply copying and doing a cheaper
their labor markets actually quite
expensive relative to many other
emerging countries now so they're losing
out to them so they've got to become
innovative and that's what's so
interesting about someone like Jack
Marit alibaba he has the is
extraordinary events Alibaba as ten
years old they had an event the other
week where they had 27,000 people in a
stadium all of whom were what Jack
McCall's netra printers which are sort
of people who are running a small
business and they're basically doing
e-commerce via his website and he's
actually talking about now not b2c
business to consumer but see to be
consumed at a business where you're
creating a whole industry around the
custom are actually telling the firm
what it wants what will the couple of
customer wants and actually leading to a
really high level of customization I
don't even think you're seeing in the
West in terms of the products that are
produced so this is the real challenge
for China can it go from being a
follower in terms of innovation to being
a leader and you know I think there's
every reason to think that the talent
and the energy that they have there and
the awareness that they need to just
keep growing as fast they can and at the
same time to deal with the social
problems they face which is going to be
will probably be a leader in things like
green energy that they have to solve
these problems and that's going to
actually make them very very another two
over the next few years
I think the US has a schizophrenic view
to the growth that's happening in
developing countries like India and
China India and China both taking jobs
from America in a way and so that seems
very threatening on the other hand there
is an awareness that actually China and
it particularly is providing a lot of
the money that America is using to to
spend and enjoy a high quality of life
so a lot of Treasury bonds of walk by
the Chinese and there is an underlying
recognition that when countries like
India and China come out of poverty the
world as a whole gets wealthier which
means we all win it's a win-win
situation and so the next five years are
going to be about adjusting to a world
where America is not the dominant
economy anymore but it's still a very
important economy and it has to find a
more satisfactory relationship with
these emerging economies and that's
going to mean a bit of giving a bit of
take and on both sides but I think there
will be ultimately a better relationship
between America and China and India
because it will become a more equal
relationship and I think gradually the
public will understand in America that
is not a threat fundamentally the
America if it sorts out his own domestic
issues which are largely about
retraining the labor force so that
people can do jobs that aren't done more
cheaply overseas this will be very much
a win-win
china india i think have a lot of
opportunities because they're still very
many people who aren't in the mainstream
labour market they have india in
particular has a very young population
that is getting educated fast but their
education system still has a long way to
go before it's a good as it could be
china there's a lot of brainpower a lot
of engineers there and this is still a
period of humanity of human history
where there's a great deal of potential
for innovation and so I think there are
great opportunities there the issue is
that labor markets are becoming globally
integrative which means that the price
of Chinese labor and of Indian labor is
increasingly moving up to global levels
and therefore if if they if they unless
they're actually adding real value
relative to what you could do in America
is not going to be just simply a matter
of cost-cutting it's gonna be about
figuring out a way that they do things
better